-We´re hanging out
with Blake Shelton!
Blake Shelton!
New record´s out Friday.
You can see him on "The Voice."
Blake and I are
about to go head-to-head
in a game of
Caramel Apple Roulette.
Higgins, would you like
to explain how this works?
-[ Coughing, laughing ]
-What is it?
-Hey, there he is.
-Yes, Jimmy.
Here...would appear
to be 12 caramel apples.
-Okay.
-But don´t be fooled!
Eight of these are apples.
Four are raw onions.
[ Audience ohhs ]
You and Blake will take turns
taking one caramel apple
and taking a bite.
You won´t know which are apples
and which are onions!
But once you choose an apple --
-What the hell are you doing?
-I don´t know.
Everything´s off today.
Once you choose an apple, you
must take a bite and swallow it.
No put-backs!
First one to bite
into two onions loses!
Blake, as guest of the show,
you will choose
the first caramel apple.
-This is the dumbest thing.
Yeah.
-Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Which one?
-Which are apples?
-Am I choosing right now?
-Yeah. Which are onions?
Which are apples?
That one looks good.
-That one looks like an apple.
-That looks like
a Texakoma apple.
-You know what?
I´m calling bull crap on you.
-Good luck!
-Now wait a minute.
If this is an onion, do I lose,
or I get another chance?
-No, you get two onions!
[ Cackles evilly ]
-[ Laughs ]
Go for it man.
Just take a bite and have faith.
-I´m only here ´cause
Seth Meyers was booked.
-Yeah, I understand.
Thank you. I know. I heard.
It´s an onion.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Blake, I´m so happy you´re here.
[ Laughs ]
-Good luck!
-All right.
-Which are apples --
-I´m not going to sell one album
off this stupid crap.
No one cares about this.
-♫ Ba-da, ba-da, ba-da,
bahp, bahp ♫
♫ Happy Halloween, dude ♫
♫ Happy Hallo -- ♫
It feels a little heavy.
It feels like an apple.
I feel good. I´m confident.
Pretty confident dude.
Things are going great.
-That´s a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That´s more like it!
-Ohh!
-Now we got some drama!
It´s like the
World Series, buddy!
1-1.
Yeah!
-Caramelized onions.
That´s disgusting.
How did you swallow this?
-Stop fingering everything.
What are you doing?
What is it? What are you doing?
-Right.
-Was it good?
-Oh, it´s disgusting.
Uh, Blake, pick that one.
-No, that didn´t work.
-Oh, come on. That guy.
-Ooh!
-Ohh!
[ Cackles evilly ]
[ Laughter ]
-1-1. It´s like
the World Series.
Good luck.
Go get ´em.
Feels like an apple.
Ohh! [ Laughs ]
That is the game!
Ladies and gentlemen!
[ Laughs ]
Thank you for coming.
Blake Shelton is performing
a brand-new song
at the end of the show tonight.
Andrea Martin joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.